sup guys you know how I like football so
I got my boys with me here we're gonna
play some giant finger flick football oh
wow slightly weathered cuz it was using
another challenge take it from here into
the goal it's one point it is enough zip
this is the one point line take it from
here you get one point three point line
five point line okay guys you ready oh
wait I get to add come on are we ready
okay
go team us whatever our name is my rhyme
potato history of finger football has
that happens but but but God yeah hi now
it's ride ride sir need going forward
III I've never three yeah okay no I'll
try okay
angry
I'm ready okay it goes right Lyle Jesus
you had anger in that kick little lower
a little oh poor get him warm get hard
alright this time Atticus I I broke a
world record you made him be a little
straighter than anybody I don't run
are you ready all right oh that was just
like the nest boy hey guys look here so
softbox everyone hit road 83 probably
could have pulled it back oh go to the
posts I don't know I have I found my
superpower my one pedal I should have
been a puncher where I discover I'm
actually one kick man
so okay ready ready full start sharp
your left side left side this measure up
this prize oh good good after good
hustle out there buddy
no points oh boy
Oh scream thank you does that mean I
don't know
okay all right I took footage it does
the whole point
you know walruses are like a wild card
I'm gonna do like a little I call this
the one the ballerina
okay let me go embarrassing me right now
Oh again
oh yeah okay okay ready yeah
whoa holy crap nice running no that's
out listen out oh [ __ ] favorite a double
saw what I did 13 now I gotta I gotta
follow up you have a breakdown on 1800
loser you are who you are you're a big
loser focus ballerina dancer the master
dang it
you got you got my head down Brian going
over oh I try and wait too long oh come
on oh come on I got it all right you got
it go yeah whoo good job dude come on
boy
yes mark just wants to see how hard he
can kick it and go mark alright game it
was a close game of our jam finger shut
up giant finger flick but ball in the
end the other team won too much a smelly
and stupid as they are so check out
their channel hit cheated
I honestly broke a world record it
wasn't even on camera
those amazed it went all the way around
the world dream came back in 60 days I
proposed a new nickname mr. walrus legs
alright
so mr. walrus red leg out peace be with
you brush your teeth brush teeth don't
touch day floss go to school do your
homework read to eat your veggies eat
your veggies guys alright be smile of
knowledge yeah universities for the same
amount of education it's true community
college doesn't matter were you doing
heist cost-effective solution deal